I think it's just seeing my intro ah
into the woods so into the woods it's a
fairytale movie encompassing a lot of
fairy tales got Red Riding Hood Jack and
the Beanstalk just a bunch of things
that are interweaving and they're all
doing it while they're singing not like
lame is a Rob were they seeing
ninety-eight percent of the dialogue
it's a good 90 percent a lot of singing
if you don't like that know that this
has a lot of it basically Meryl Streep
is a witch and she's like I need these
trinkets and I'll help you if you help
me so now it's pretty much a scavenger
hunt for trinkets of fairy tale variety
made for a pretty entertaining movie not
only did the people do a good job in
this movie I mean Meryl Streep does a
good job in the movie Emily Blunt Anna
Kendrick all these people are doing
really well and they're singing really
well not just like someone sings
sometimes the arrangements intertwine
and interweave with other arrangements
you're like whoa that's who the
harmonies that's really cool I like that
stuff I like good music in a movie and
the movie has fine momentum and you're
enjoying the fairy tales because you
grew up on the fairy tale so it's cool
to see them all in a movie together
however it's missing Robert Carlyle owes
Rumpelstiltskin magic comes with a price
Terry and at a point the movies wrapping
up and you're like all right yeah it's
so just wrapping up a little soon but I
get it and I'm buying it I'm enjoying it
but then the movie does something you
should not have done kept going and the
movie doesn't end there no it goes on
for another while is such a detached
segment you enjoyed everything for what
it was you want to be an optimist about
it and at this point if this other
segment just feels like the movie was
done I know it's based on a play so I
made the plays the same way sure we
still feel like the game makers of the
movie were like hey all right
or we could end here or you play a joke
on everybody and see how often we can
get them to check their watches in the
movie theater sounds like fun so that's
what's happening because you're checking
your watch like is this movie over yeah
it should have ended back then now it's
still going it kind of reminds me of
someone you get into a conversation with
at Thanksgiving or something that one
family member that one uncle just just
has to put his foot in his mouth puts
his foot in his mouth
and he just spends the next half an hour
trying to dig himself out of it but the
more he tries to dig out of it the more
he just starts digging his own grave
you're like you shoulda quit while you
were kind of ahead now you're behind
it's a bummer because he just
grinds everything to a halt derp a
couple twists and turns the last quarter
of this movie makes where you're like it
just kind of conflicts with everything
else and it almost feels like it flushes
characters down the toilet in the end
into the woods if you like fairy tales
you're gonna enjoy this movie if you
like musicals you're gonna enjoy this
movie like takes everything you like
from your childhood weaves them into one
story and I think that's really cool the
performances are solid in the movie I
mean there are people who sing better
than other people but no one in this
movie was actually the worst sees
there's not that Russell Crowe from lame
is where you're like shouldn't have done
that
I felt the movie works for what it was
but that last 25% of the movie just
completely kills the mood in the
previous 75 if the movie had stopped
when I thought it was gonna stop I would
have been like alright I was a good time
to alcohol required it was a good fairy
tale romp through fairytale land and the
woods in the movie kept going and just
started killing it now I gotta say into
the woods is a pretty good time if
you're drunk
yeah now it's a party oh hey I could
sober up and just watch 75% of moving
you'll still be good you can watch 75%
of the movie and walk out completely
sober or just start knocking him back
for that last 25% right into the woods
have you seen it what did you think
about it what's your favorite musical of
all time everything comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more